so this week Adam 22 has been coping and
it has been the saddest hope I have ever
seen in my life so Adam 22 pimped out
his wife you know he had her do a porn
scene with another guy
um and the cope has just been amazing
watching him like rationalize this in
real time because his first gut reaction
was oh I was a little jealous at first I
didn't want to be embarrassed I I I
didn't want people to talk about it and
now he's just you know leaning into it I
guess
um let's let's pull the footage of him
and his wife talking about this porn
scene no jumper coolest podcast in the
world and guys never say that I don't
give you what you want you've all been
talking about it you all want to hear it
I got the one and only Lin of the plug
my wife on the podcast to talk about
recent events I'm laughing because I'm
thinking about how like I'd probably
never come on the podcast again but if
another guy somehow I'm allowed to go on
the podcast
you thought you were never gonna come on
the podcast again I mean it's just like
you know no one wants the line of the
plug interview
someone else and now it's like oh she
needs an interview okay you did an adult
scene with someone else
when I think about it I'm like okay cool
well when you were in your like Mom Tick
Tock era
probably that wasn't going to be the
thing that made me like okay let's let's
get around I had I had you on here what
a year and a half ago with Flaco
yeah I can't remember why we did that
just just give you a little press yeah
get some stuff out there I feel more
comfortable if he was here I feel really
like uncomfortable because it's just you
and I and we're gonna talk about this in
front of my brother-in-law Josh he's not
paying attention he's not even in here
oh he left thank God I was like Josh is
in here don't put Josh on blast
um it's felt comfortable no but this
might actually be the first time that
you and I have been on this podcast
together just you and I right uh yeah it
is the first time that's great also we
got married we did get married that
didn't constitute me coming on here but
in this event it seems like an
afterthought after the last week yeah
not like actually but in terms of
content yeah
um yeah I didn't even really talk about
the marriage that much on here because
it just seemed like it was so nice it
was great it feels different because
everyone's like do you feel different
now I'm like absolutely not yes it's the
exact same we made it official we had a
nice party with the friends and family
and everything went on the honeymoon but
it's like it's not like the rules
changed it's not like oh like we're
gonna do things differently now we
already had the house the kid you know
yeah we did most of the serious stuff in
advance the marriage was like all right
I guess we should just do this too let's
let's finish up let's wrap it up yeah I
guess so okay this this is the first
thing that I thought might be useful for
us to lay out is let's lay out the
chronological order of how the idea of
you even working with other people
became a thing because I have a memory
of maybe six months ago where you said
something like do you really think that
we're gonna go our whole lives without
ever sleeping with other people and in
the context of like I think we're
talking about swinging at first yeah I
mean because people don't really know
this about you and I but you just
mentioned it on the podcast so now I can
talk about it that we had a threesome
early in our relationship with another
guy and that was just like we went out
we partied we had like a really fun hot
sexual experience and we're always kind
of down for like a little bit of freaky
things it was like two or three other
people who like we're not there to see
us but they just happened to be in the
room because we're all just hanging out
this is back in the Adam and Lena party
era that didn't really last that long
and at that time to be totally honest
you were pretty much a random girl to me
yeah we didn't have any kind of like
emotional connection oh my God that's
where we were in our lives we went to
emo night okay and
um I've always been somebody who
throughout my life there's been a bunch
of different times where me and my homie
might put girl together always enjoyed
it
I enjoyed it with you that night but
then once we started to actually get
closer and closer to like dating it
became like no we're not talking about
that anymore we literally never talked
about it again
we maybe didn't talk about it for like
five six years
is as soon as he has feelings for the
girl he doesn't want to share
it's like he's like going against his
biology like he's like oh we never
talked about it again but you can just
tell naturally he doesn't want to share
this woman yet the modern era is like
trying to program him and take away what
I mean that's honestly part of what
makes the relationship between
that's that's part of what that's part
of what makes the relationship between
men and women beautiful like men should
be protective of the women that they
care about and yet they're trying to
like deprogram that from him they're
trying like the culture is trying to say
that that's controlling that he
shouldn't feel like that and you can
tell naturally he agrees with more
traditional people yet
yeah yeah you see pull pull the footage
back and then all of a sudden and also
my my friend went on to date the guy for
a really long time so that's all
probably also why we didn't talk about
it that is a good point yeah
um but like okay when I think about that
version of us and the version of us that
isn't always going to do who's just very
into sex and likes to try fun and new
experiences I was just like are we
really never gonna have an experience
like that even off camera ever again and
what spread that conversation I think
was the fact that we had had multiple
different couples on plug talk where
either they were into The Swinging thing
or they just did with other people
separately and stuff and slowly it
started to seem like well maybe this
rule is kind of arbitrary well I think
for us it was also seeing those couples
and seeing how turned on they got by
having those sexual experiences with
other people which we had a lot in our
relationship when we would bring girls
in like I would be so much more into you
after and you'd be into me it was like
seeing your partner enjoying someone
else's hot it turns you on so it's like
I feel like that is sort of like worn
off for me because this is the problem
for women women okay because women when
we see the other men select our guy it's
basically it's pre-selection oh sorry
when when it's this goes back to this
false reality that men and women are
equal because she gets turned on when
other women select her her husband right
she thinks that men are the same and
they get they get turned on when other
men select their woman but it's not true
it's not the same women um basically
like you know back in the caveman days
or whatever if we saw that a man could
get other women we one knew she selected
him so that means that
that if he could if she selected him
there was a reason that she selected him
into if he could take care of other
women that means if he could take care
of and protect other women that means
that he could take care of and protect
us too it's called pre-selection but men
and women are not the same and you can
see Adam's natural inclination to stay
away from this sort of stuff yet
they just try to deny reality I'm so
used to it a little bit that is the
problem with us like what I feel like
you with the guitar to watch me have sex
with someone else because we already
know you think it's hot we did it once
but that was like my dick is in your
mouth and he's your vagina yeah I'm not
saying you DP'd me but like right but
I'm just saying it's not like I was
sitting in the corner because there's a
whole narrative okay I don't think
you're a cook are you gonna go with this
well it does seem kind of stupid okay so
there's the cuck thing is different
because cucks are supposed to be weak
and humiliated they want to be made to
feel lesser and I don't think that
that's you I think that there's like the
more swinging side of things where it's
like you are turned on by your wife
enjoying someone and then and then she
comes back to you and you guys enjoy
your own personal sexual experiences
more with each other because she did
that right but I mean you have barely
even done the thing that you're kind of
inferring which is like me going and
[__] another girl and just like
telling you about it because the one
time I think there's only one time on
plug talk where you woke up and you were
sick as a dog and so you couldn't come
you couldn't come to set that day but it
was a girl shut up Alvin Jay everybody
sign up on uh onlyplugtalk.com everyone
thinks I have beef for their navigation
no no
oliver.com if you want to see the scene
but me and Alvin Jay we did a scene
while you were at home sick as a dog and
uh you didn't want to see it afterwards
you were actually before you left the
house I was in bed I remember I was like
okay go do the scene don't tell me how
it went when you come back and I don't
want to see any clips from it yeah which
is interesting because when you came
back from doing this scene the other day
I wanted to hear about it
I I wanted to know what I was going to
find out I wanted to know like what's
the most extreme thing that happened how
did it play out that's more like me
wanting to like manage whatever the
Fallout might have been more so than
like trying to avoid I don't know like
why did you text Adam after the scene I
don't even tell them the scene's done
I'm just like do you want anything from
Dave's fried chicken I was just like act
like it didn't happen
that is true yeah but Okay so we've
we've had I don't know maybe 200
threesomes over the year that was our
rough estimate maybe like almost 100 on
plug Talk Plus a bunch in our private
life plus a bunch for your only fans and
yeah I don't know over time we did just
kind of start to sort of have that
conversation and at first I think we
considered the idea of like swinging on
camera and then that kind of scene you
always suggested guys I would never want
to [__] yeah that probably was always
unfair trade intentional on my part yeah
probably uh but
he would suggest then that she didn't
it's like it seeps out you know what I
mean like their biology seeps out of
them trying to like erase their biology
and the way he feels about it and like
it's a cope it's so obviously a cope he
said
it was intentional that he picked guys
that she wouldn't want to f
Adam I'm calling me crazy maybe this
wasn't the best idea I thank you for
giving me content to talk about this
week but just you know we had a nice
interview maybe I I don't know if I
would go down this road all right yeah
like it just kind of seemed like well if
you are going to do it for the first
time we should roll it out in a way that
actually is as exciting as possible yeah
I mean I I
a rollout
rollout like I knew it was
you I have a pretty big adult fan
audience and they literally every single
comment on anything I post is like do a
scene with BBC do a scene with whatever
this person black whatever so I knew
that my fans were gonna be excited but
and I knew that the wedding thing was
going to be a factor because it's like
why all of a sudden after you get
married but I didn't think it was going
to be this big but it's weird because we
had been talking about it before the
wedding and sort of like you know the
idea was in the it was in the air so you
know as um the cope continues
they have this adult star that she
screwed
call in call in pull it up pull it up oh
oh I'm getting a call
oh okay I'm gonna take this
oh hello look who it is Mr Jason love
how you doing man
it was good it was good uh we're just
doing a little podcast here and uh
figured that we would uh you know have a
little conversation with you to see
exactly how all this was for you as well
oh my
cool cool that's why I chimed in catch
y'all see what's up definitely so is
there what's the vibe like between you
guys anything I should know about there
I don't think the vibe I think it's like
a business thing but I feel just very
uncomfortable with this right now
a little uncomfortable
can you tell him how nervous I was
like so nervous oh my God I feel so
wrong right now just
okay now but a lot of people have like a
cheating fetish like I'm not gonna lie
like this I feel like you do yeah
cheating I've done in the past was I'm a
little bit turned on by the fact that I
was doing something underhand or take
take myself out of it but like if you're
[__] a girl and you know she has a
boyfriend she's doing something wrong
that is kind of hot
is it a little bit you see he knows
it's kind of like the adrenaline the
adrenaline like I feel so guilty even if
I was The Other Woman okay so Jason give
me a genuine review
you notice that
they cut something I wonder what they
cut there how was it
you went like a number scale or just
like
numbers sounds like it could be hurtful
but if it's a high number sure like a
four
really nine out of ten who's a 10.
well obviously her oh well it was a nine
out of ten I never I never grasped the
entire tin before it's like you gotta
leave room for something that could
possibly top the next one okay yeah I'll
take a million then that's fair wow
you said a nine out of ten
wow
he's like flirting with her in front of
him he's like oh she was so nervous but
I was like it's
oh this is making me crunch
it's just you know as a guy if you allow
that level of disrespect oh
the thing is society has fallen so bad
that people don't even recognize the
signals and the signs of a weak man like
literally if you are in the midst of
other men
in like maybe like a formal set or
anything you're not even allowed to
approach another man's woman without
approaching the man first
but here
I mean we all understand is the porn
industry but the reality is like
this same Adam 22 is not going to be
comfortable sharing his boxers or his
toothbrush with another man but yet he's
very happy to share his woman
um okay yeah so a lot of people want to
know uh I don't know just like if I
should feel diminished as a man as a
result of this like the cuck narrative
is very very yes yes you should Adam
yes quick answer yes yes yes
yes
strong I just want to get your thoughts
on that and if if how people should
think about that in in the context of me
being you know the the silent third
party and all this
well I don't know like if you look at it
in the business aspect then basically it
was just a job you know she's high up in
her ranks I'm high up in my ranks that's
true together obviously would make the
most amounts of money so it's not so
much being a cook if you comfortable
with it y'all communicating the product
obviously she said y'all did so it's not
really a cooked situation it's more of
like two people coming and making an
understanding yeah you know so if you
cool with it then you know it is what it
is me personally I don't know if I have
enough in me to allow it but everyone's
different everyone have different levels
of
even him he's like you know
I don't have enough in me you could tell
that this what is his name Jason love
thinks this is like
you can tell he's losing respect for
Adam you can you can just tell
because he's saying I don't think I have
enough in me to allow that implying that
somehow Adam is like on a moral High
Ground by allowing him to screw his
woman but he knows what he's doing yeah
he knows this is literally Alpha Beta
like literally go and look at all
throughout history there is no Alpha man
that would ever let his woman sleep with
another guy even for money and it's even
worse when you already have money so if
if Adam was broke I could kind of maybe
understand but he has money so like
there's no excuse them saying well they
want to break records and all that
that's that is total cap I think
um his wife wears the pants in the
relationship and then he was scared that
if he didn't let her do it she was
either going to do it anyways or she was
going to break up his family or mess up
his money or basically she probably in
fact the way I see it I think she
probably blackmailed him into doing it
because he's let it sleep a couple of
times that she brought up the idea so
well I bet you he wanted to make her
happy and she kept bringing up these
guys
like because I just think he's just kind
of like trying to make her happy you
know like and she you could tell how
much she likes him too but you can just
tell like she's like oh I was so nervous
you're not nervous around a guy you
don't like I say mental majority well it
would be kind of weird for you to find a
dude bigger than you maybe they could
resurrect Andre the Giant or something
maybe you could get Brock Lesnar to come
through and cut it up for you but I mean
you're kind of like with the biggest
dude that I could think of I don't know
it's going to be tough for you to find a
bigger guy
not just the size it's everything that
goes into it that makes it you know
definitely Lena is just like shriveling
up into a ball right now I can see how
uncomfortable this is making yes this is
making me very uncomfortable and I'm
glad that he's only you know on zoom and
not here right now do you think that
would be awkward yes also I feel like
I'd feel very a lot of sexual attention
and I felt like we would have to do a
scene oh if you guys were broken see
she's out of control now she's on a tear
I've been known to have that effect I
apologize see all right now I'm gonna
have to really mind you next time you're
going to an adult event that he's gonna
be at right no but I would be turning on
if you were there oh yeah it's like
you're part of it
so you think that if me and you go out
to a party and we see him that there's a
chance that we'd all end up hooking up
after I don't know what his stance is on
working with you oh wow good point yeah
I don't I don't care oh hell yeah I get
it in regardless damn that would be yeah
I could say that that would probably
kind of make me feel like I had put a
cap on this whole situation if we all
did it together well maybe that is the
three-way that we should do because that
would be
pretty viral rather than just some
random guy right
yeah it would be crazy
as long as I'm not sitting in a chair
with my [__] arms right behind my
back or whatever you gotta hold the
camera for one shot all right so now I
gotta rewrite this group yeah what do
what do people need to know about Jason
love since like you're kind of I almost
feel like a large percentage maybe even
the majority of the photos that you're
going to be taking over the next year or
so you're gonna it's gonna be people
saying like you're the dude who [__]
Adam 22 his wife I don't know I mean I
know you get recognized all the time but
it's kind of an interesting scenario
that you're in now right
I got stopped on the street like four or
five times already normally it's just to
talk to me about me but then they're
like oh you no jumping the wife I'm like
yeah I guess
wow insane
um my wife bro yeah you're gonna get
more of those offers see I've only had a
couple people say that to me I'm sure he
gets that all the time
right so if we do choose to have another
kid how am I gonna know it's mine and
not oh my God I can't no cut what what
why would you even let that be a
possibility oh my and the crazy thing is
he doesn't need money that's the crazy
thing he's just doing this to do it and
the funny thing is it's a me me culture
where you're gonna sacrifice money
you're gonna love to be 80 or 90. your
kids are also going to live to be 80 or
90.
and now now
your kids have to deal with the
consequences of your decision
and it's so funny because they'll try to
rationalize it and be like Oh my kids
will be fine what if they're not
what if they're not like this is the
crazy thing you crazy parents your kids
grow up one day and they talk and you
can't control what they say forever
so if you permanently damage them from
doing this [__]
I I hope it was worth it to you I really
do because for what money
money
that he doesn't even need that's the
crazy part
oh God go the next one
he's actually a good interviewer too
he's actually a really good interviewer
that's the crazy thing is he didn't have
to do any of this like like I didn't
even know his corn stuff I used to know
his interviews he would do with Like
Rappers and stuff and like they were
really good he did one with Kevin
Samuels it was really good like I'm sure
he wouldn't have as much money but he
still could have been famous and
successful he's a smart business guy yet
he he electively chooses to do this
yeah
so he's coping all around all around
Twitter
so Logan Paul tweets engaged to my best
friend how cute is that very cute go
down go down let her sleep with another
dude
then then go to the next one she says he
says
this is the next story I'm gonna cover
but Elon Musk tweets at Zuckerberg
calling him a [__] he said Zuck is a
cuck Adam 22 says you say that like it's
a bad thing yes Adam
I understand you know being funny all
that stuff but this is a bad thing
don't release the footage put it away
forever
put it away but this is what we get when
we have modern relationships and women
that run relationships we have open
relationships from guys that are tall
good looking and have money accepting
this debauchery and type of behavior but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments and let me know what stories
you want me to cover tomorrow on Pearl
daily like the video on your way out
guys subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time